[Music]
hey guys it's episode 187
of congratulations
[Music]
oh you guys what's going on listen
before we even get started um
i uh it's uh i i
i um i wanted to say that go
you know you can support the show with
our patreon but also you can buy merch
we got merch out there we got the
the life rips uh hoodies and the shorts
and the
and um i'm also coming out with some new
[ __ ]
uh and some socks i believe but uh just
living it up showing you how life rips
because life can rip if you make it rip
and that's it and that's and i dude i
don't make the rules i mean i make the
rules
i made that rule pretty much uh it's the
only rule i've ever made but
um no that's not true actually if you
ask kristin
definitely i've made more rules uh than
uh than i should have i made that rule
about how
she gets on me about how i eat out of
the side of my mouth i put the [ __ ]
when i eat food i take the food and i
don't
chomp it when i was a kid i never wanted
to chomp it directly because some shit's
too hard
and some shit's too uh difficult to eat
i didn't want to chomp it directly on my
front teeth
because number one it was too difficult
and number two the food was too hard and
number three
i didn't ever want to get food stuck in
my in my teeth right in the front teeth
rather get food stuck in the back teeth
so people can't see that [ __ ]
right so um she was like
i was eating tuna earlier today the the
pieces not the [ __ ] not tuna fish but
not the tuna fish salad what the [ __ ]
they call it but the regular pieces
and i went to go and i was just taking
the slabs they were seared you know and
i'd taken the slabs
and i was just going to i count and i
was eating that and she was like i don't
like how you do that and i was like
first of all let me live number one
number two it's better to do that and
she was like
why and i said i said i made i decided
when i was a kid
i was gonna be doing that because it's
better that way and i created that way
of eating and she said
you didn't create it and i said yes i
did and she said you know it's so [ __ ]
to [ __ ] have to try and think of a
way to eat
when you can just eat and i was like no
freaking
way dude it is not [ __ ] and i thought
of it before i even started eating
from the front like this so i thought
about it
without even having to correct it and i
did it the right way so now that we got
past that
great and that's rule two now what is
going on here why is everything so
distracting why is everyone looking
under the table
what's going on is it the dog
okay so the dog the trash dog is eating
a fortune cookie that's fine let him
[ __ ] do it let's not all go like this
oh like there's a fire under the table
so i get [ __ ] up telling my [ __ ]
great
eating at the side of my mouth story
okay
um i do great stories and when
people are looking at the other way when
i'm telling a great story and they're
going oh oh oh oh
then i get all [ __ ] up like a fire's
under the table okay
and i'm not mad but i'm just speaking
very passionately because this is my
passion baby
whoa this is my passion baby whoa so
yeah
life rips if you let it rip life rips if
you make it rip and it's a ripping
mindset dude
so uh go to chrisley.com and you can go
see all that [ __ ] merch it's hot [ __ ]
dude
i'm a fashionista let's start with
mother's day man it was mother's day and
it was beautiful
and i put up a nice post um on instagram
for uh kristen cause
you know it was mother's day and i
wanted to be very loving and uh
it was nice it was really nice and i was
crying i was writing the caption and i
was writing the as i was writing the
caption i was crying
and she's like why are you crying and i
was like ah it's nothing
because what do you say i'm on instagram
and so uh so i put it up
and but i wanted to say happy mother's
day
to all the mothers out there and i hope
you celebrated with your mother i
love my mother very much she's a very
sweet lady and i am very happy
for the way that she raised me and i
just wanted to say that because
sometimes
we don't sometimes we get emo on this
podcast
and sometimes we keep it real
occasionally we do both and this is both
we're being a little bit emo but we're
also keeping it real i love my mommy
okay
and that's that um but i also wanted to
say something else because i put this on
my instagram story
and i think it's important to say emo
keeping it real
the worlds collide and uh but i wanted
to say
it must be hard for people who have lost
their mothers
mother's day must be hard for people who
have lost their mothers
especially if it just happened this is
your first mother's day
where you don't have your mom it's got
to be hard and nobody ever [ __ ] talks
about that
nobody ever talks about those people or
how it might be hard and nobody ever
talks about that and
and it's probably still hard even if you
lost your mom 20 years ago mother's day
is a reminder that you
your mom isn't alive on this earth
anymore and
that's that's got to be hard and i just
wanted to say
because i put on my instagram story and
after i did i was like i don't hear too
many people talking about that so i
wanted to say this on a larger platform
here this podcast
and um i just wanted to say that
i'm thinking about you guys too um and
i'm sure it's bittersweet because you
have fond memories of your moms and all
that stuff uh
but uh anyway uh let's get into some
silly goose time because that was very
emo and very real
um and i just wanted to also talk about
my dude i was at my parents place
for actual mother's day and i don't need
the phone up there because i have the
notes here
um i was at my parents place for actual
mother's day
and my dad made pasta now my dad does
cooking in the family
and my dad rips it cooking dude it
really does he makes a good
pasta sauce and that is so new jersey
you know
uh his pasta sauce is good dude it gets
you here it gets you right here
his gravy the gravy he makes
uh it's so new jersey to call pasta
sauce gravy
makes you think you think a [ __ ]
turkey gravy all over the pasta it'd be
so [ __ ] gross
and and a pizza pie
ew anyway he makes a great gravy sauce
you understand sorry little kids but i'm
gonna be
i'm gonna kill a clown today anyway um
my dad makes a a good [ __ ] sauce and
he made it
and he killed that [ __ ] sometimes he
puts meatballs in it but sometimes he's
filling it a little bit and he'll put
sausage in it
and sometimes he's feeling it a bit more
and he'll put steak in it he'll put
chunks of steak just in the pasta
and if you're not italian or if you're
not familiar with pasta
uh like my ex-girlfriend just didn't
like pasta and i was just like
excuse me are you human but she just
didn't like pasta that much
and i have another buddy who pretends he
doesn't like it because he likes to have
six-packs he's like i don't like pasta i
ate enough when i was a kid
and i'm just like you're making excuses
just say you don't want to eat it
because you want that washboard tummy
so if you're one of those people if
you're not one of those if you're one of
those people that doesn't
really live by the pasta you know my
family we ate pasta every other day but
dude
um we ate uh
you can throw steak and pasta but you
might be like steak
chunks a steak and pasta yeah
it's good
it was mother's day my dad was doing
something special so he was putting
chunks of steak
and sausage in bow tie pasta
all right that's what he did with his
[ __ ] beautiful gravy you understand
so we get to the house i noticed the
chunks of steak and the sausage and the
pasta and i'm like
damn so i took some out of the bowl and
i put
three pieces of sausage in my bowl with
my pasta okay
and i went to bring it back down to the
table and eat it
now i watch my dad take a bunch of
[ __ ]
pasta a bunch of pieces of steaks and
some sausage put in the bowl i go
sit goes to sit down and as he's walking
down i say
hey um how many
pieces of meat
do you think you like to have in each
bowl of pasta
and he says i have no idea
this is the thing here where
what with with just it sets me apart
from my dad like if you were to meet me
and then
see my dad out somewhere you'd be like
that's crystalline his dad
he just looks like me a lot
and even more than that he acts like me
but this is the part where it's like he
was the teacher and he taught me and i'm
the student and i surpassed it because
this dude
my dad would definitely
get on somebody for saying the wrong
thing or not being specific enough
but not as much as me so now i'm so he
says i have no idea
and i'm just like how could you eat
pasta
with chunks of meat in it and not know
how many pieces of meat generally you
might like
in each bowl okay and i said
and i left it alone i left it alone
because sometimes
kristen talks to me about my tone and
i'm like i don't want to be doing the
tone
let's learn from this experience and
let's not talk about
let's not push you understand but i want
to know
right that's where i get into trouble
that's where your boy gets into trouble
when we're hanging out having a good
time somebody does something it's not
specific enough and i ask them about it
and then they say something that's still
not specific enough
and then i get this but okay but i want
to know
that's when your boy is on a slippery
slope okay
so why back off because kristen's there
and even though yeah sure i got my my
brother there that's definitely willing
to back me up
because he's very specific too
uh i back off and i chill and i'm like
you know what i got my son here let's
just be a family so we sit down and
we're eating
pasta and everyone's having a good time
your boy can't drop it your boy can't
drop the feeling
your boy cannot drop the feeling
my dad lied my dad lied to me in my head
my dad lied to me
he said he never thought about how many
pieces of meat that he would want in the
[ __ ] pasta okay
so i'm eating the [ __ ] thing and i'm
eating and i'm eating my sausage and i'm
like that's the first piece you know i'm
eating this thing i'm eating the [ __ ]
pasta and i go there's the second piece
that i knew i put in there all right
cool i got one more piece because i know
three pieces are in there you put three
to four pieces of meat in the [ __ ]
pasta
when the bowls are this size so i say
hey dad you know
when you said you put a bunch
when i asked you how many pieces of meat
goes in a bowl of pasta
you said you have no idea and he's just
eating the [ __ ] just he says
yeah and i'm like
well but what what do you mean you have
no idea
that there is how many pieces of meat
would be in the bowl and he just
goes like this
and he kind of like giggles a little bit
but he's like can i just eat my [ __ ]
pasta and i'm just like yeah but
certainly there's a difference between
one piece of meat in the bowl of pasta
[Laughter]
and 25 pieces of meat in the bowl of
pasta right
and he says yeah i said would you put 25
pieces of meat in a bowl of pasta
and he was like that would just be a
bowl of meat and i said okay
so you know not to do that right and he
said yeah and i
i and i said what about 24 and he said
that's too much
i said well what about 23 and he said
and i said 22 and i went down
i got to about 19 and he says
i just don't want are you going to keep
going down the whole time i don't want
to
and i was like because you know there's
a number
that matters there's a number of pieces
of meat in one pasta bowl that matters
where you go like this okay yeah that's
not too much
so now we got a number dude we got a
number
is it nine is it eight is it five
because i looked down and i counted i
said how many pieces of meat you got and
he says i don't know
um well i ate three and there's four
left
so i said wow so seven's a lot he said
yeah i said did you know you put seven
in there
and he said nah i didn't think about it
and i said that is absolutely
bonkers to me man you can make the bowl
the way you want to make it
and then eat it the way you want to eat
it but you don't even [ __ ] think
about that huh
and he said no he said i don't give a
[ __ ]
and i was like that is unbelievable matt
what do you think about that because
i'm in a round table discussion now it's
[ __ ] live and in charge with bill
maher or whatever the [ __ ] his show is
called
what's it called real time yeah real
time
live and in charge dude so i'm talking
and i say matt and he says what and i
said what do you think and he says
oh yeah no i mean i think that's crazy
and he said and he's i said well how
many pieces of meat do you think should
go in a bowl and he said
about four and i said that's about how
many pieces of meat i think should be in
a pasta bowl
and uh basically dude don't live a life
where you don't know how much pieces of
meat you want in a [ __ ] bowl
that you're gonna put in your body dude
well i'm getting a sandwich well hey
what kind of sandwich you want a turkey
sandwich that's what he would say
so what kind of [ __ ] although oh i'm
just gonna get you a pastrami sandwich
and give you that
if you don't give a [ __ ] what's going on
in the bowl that you're gonna put in
your body
i let it go ish you know we talked a
little bit about it but i let it go
ish and um
we agreed to disagree because i'm
learning your boy
is learning the bad coffee
the bad coffee it's caramel flavored
[Music]
we [ __ ] hate caramel flavor we like
regular coffee
and i drank it and it's caramel flavor
last time it was cinnamon
cinnamon flavor and before that i asked
her to get the regular flavor
and she didn't get it and i had cinnamon
flavor and i didn't like it and i said
well make sure to get the regular flavor
and
she didn't get it and now i have camera
mouth flavor whoa
it is the leagues above that cinnamon
[ __ ] dude
dude and before she made it
for me thank you very much by the way i
love that you did that
and since i'm working on myself and i'm
a good person now
i really appreciate that you made that
coffee and i think about it sometimes
i think about all of the things that you
do and thank you
you're a great mom you're a great
partner and you're just great
you know
i have a rule when somebody asks me
something twice and i respond twice
that's the end of that phase of the
conversation
so she said well
i didn't get the real the right coffee
you like and i said still
and she said yeah and i said all right
well [ __ ] whatever who cares but i
i'm not having that cinnamon [ __ ]
she says well look we've got caramel and
cinnamon and i go god that's so awful
and i said i want the caramel and she
said you shouldn't want the cinnamon i
was like man what the [ __ ] is cinnamon
cinnamon coffee is awful dude
you might as well have [ __ ]
pepto-bismol coffee and um
so she says well okay
do you want to have it um
do you want me to put sugar and milk in
it it'll help it taste better
and i said nah bro
it's hair on my chest
yes sorry for the people who only listen
that's [ __ ] hair in my chest
okay do i want sugar and cream in my
in my in my caramel coffee dude hold on
for a second
just for the people who are listening at
home let me get
it's hair on my chest okay
i i don't i don't i don't drink milk and
and sugar in my coffee i'm a 41 year old
i'm a 41 year old man
and i identify as a male okay
so i say no i don't want that in there
and she says well it might make it taste
better and i says yeah but i i would not
like that on there thank you
and she says no and then there's a beat
and i'm like cool
and i walk out and she says hey babe and
i'm like
yeah and she says i can just put a
little bit of sugar in and a little bit
of cream and it'll still taste a lot
better
and i said nah i don't want that thanks
thanks though
and she says
if i put a little bit of sugar and just
a little bit of cream
are you sure you don't want that
and i looked at her for a while and then
i went
about my business i didn't answer it a
third time
because i answered it twice
and then she said you're so [ __ ] rude
i think i was polite i answered twice
and thank you very much for making my
coffee i keep thinking about how you do
nice things like that
thank you
anyway dude
[Music]
previously on congratulations is this
cinnamon
yeah yay i don't like it like that yay
dude i picked oh my god
christian was like i have a birthday
party to go to
and i was like okay she was like so just
so you know i'm gonna be going
out and um
i don't want you know just you gotta
stay with calvin and i'm like all right
cool
and she's like all right see ya
she goes and she's like
it's from seven to nine so
i'll be home at nine you know it's like
you already know
oh th this is gonna be a 1am you know
just so you know it's at seven and
anytime you're br you're telling
anybody how long anything is you know
it's you're trying to convince yourself
if you don't
otherwise you're like i don't know i
don't know i'm just going i'll be back
it'll you know
but she's like seven to nine and we're
having dinner and
so she by by eight she's sending me
videos just of like
literally her friends crashing drinks
breaking bottles on top of their heads
one of them has a pink [ __ ] cowboy
hat on and
and and and and and kristen's literally
in the background
of the of the videos going hey
hey like i'm like this she never made
this noise before hey
hey like she's a [ __ ] like like
is on tick tock or some [ __ ] i don't
even know what that noise is but it's
like a new noise people are making
and um and so she's so she's
lit dude she's just and she is the best
at drinking dude she is the best she all
she does is laugh
and dude she hasn't been out i
it's been two years i mean i don't even
know how long she just
she's such a good mom she just wants to
be with calvin and she doesn't go out
and she was like i don't know if she was
trying to trick herself she was like i'm
not gonna
she drove the car and i was like if you
drink just make sure you have somebody
drive it back or we leave it there or
whatever the [ __ ] should be safe
she's like yeah i thought
dude lit as [ __ ] by eight okay
and so she's like
calls me at [ __ ] uh
10 something and she's like we're gonna
go back we're going we're gonna go
we're gonna did you want to come here
did you want to meet
and i'm this was in the middle of my
postmates fiasco the guy i had stolen
stolen my food i had already ordered it
again
so i'm like look babe they [ __ ] up the
postmates [ __ ] i'm ordering it again
the guy stole it and then [ __ ] i'm
still waiting and she's like
okay know it's not that far from you you
can meet i'm gonna drop the car up there
and it's all good
you gonna meet a certain down street and
i was like i'll let you know when i get
my food
so she gets to the place of the birthday
girl the house
it's not far and she's there
and she texts me
i smoked weed
and i said that's funny
are you good and she texts me
a bunch of s's
and i write that's true and she writes
yeah it is
and then she calls me and i pick up and
she hangs up
and then i say y'all good
and she texts me help me
and i say babe you want me to come get
you
and she says yeah and i say
okay i'll be right there and i drive
over
i know she's fine because she's with
like really trust trustworthy people and
[ __ ]
and she was sending me videos so i drive
there i get there
scrape my car on the [ __ ] because the
driveway
is like it literally is like a [ __ ]
half pipe
so i basically just crash into a wall
this is the [ __ ] friend's driveway
this is a driveway is like this this is
her friend's driveway
so i just go
open up the front door and all of a
sudden there's a horse dog
that punches me in the nuts she has a
[ __ ] hor the
the [ __ ] girl that she's friends with
has a horse dog and it [ __ ]
and it boxes dude it literally gets up
on its thing and it goes
into my nuts so now i scrape my [ __ ]
low rider and i also scrape my nuts
great cool
i got boxed in the nuts and need to go
to the auto shop
so i get there everyone's having a blast
you know when you walk into a
party there's like 11 people and you're
the person that's like going to pick
someone up and you're like
okay hey and everyone's just like
boogie nights being okay we just came to
pa honey it's just like
what's up it's boom boom boom boom i'm
bunch of in my room let's spend the
night together
now enter for f and i'm just like is um
is kristen here
and there's 11 people but somehow
there's 300 people it's just
wait have you guys seen it
and i i and i'm like where can we and
i'm
and i see her and she goes like this oh
my god the dog hit you the nuts
what's up and i'm like hey what's up and
she cugs me and she's laughing and she
goes like this and she says in my ear
she says
help me
i'm like well i'm right here i say this
is my friend eric this is my friend
dawson this is my friend lisa and
harry and perry and perry and cherry and
i'm like oh cool hi everybody i've met
all of you before i don't know why she
thinks i haven't
it's probably because she took one puff
of weed anyway
she doesn't get out much our child is at
home
and um and so i
she's like are you ready to go and i'm
like i got yeah sure you know
and she's like this is my friend he
wants to be a solo comedian
he doesn't really want to but i'm
pressuring him
that's what she said and he's like yeah
i don't know no he wants to be coming
he doesn't he shouldn't be he thinks
he's not going to be a comedian but
i'm pressuring him to be a comedian
because this is
funny he is funny
help me help me
and then [ __ ] it's her birthday and
she crashed her drinks over her head and
i broke
i have a video of it and bluetoothed it
to you is it bluetooth on
and i'll put a video to it and then so
she was wearing a pink cowboy hat
because she saw a guy
on tick tock or pink cowboy hat we got a
pink cowboy hat and then we got her an
ikea cake we got her a cake and i had
the ikea buck a hat
and i'm just like are all of these
sentences sentences that a sniper is
supposed to hear
and take one of us out because none of
them make sense
with what we're talking about
bring in the ikea cake what
got him he she's wearing a pink cowboy
hat
i
so i picked her up and uh we went home
and uh she was laughing
she was laughing and she was laughing
and then we went to bed and then we woke
up
and i tried to get her to drink a lot of
water as she was going to bed and then
we woke up and she was like
uh i don't feel good and i was like i
tried teaching half you drink drink
water
that's what you get for drinking and
doing one puff
puff of weed don't do weed dude
it's bad for you
god man
now you should do weed if you want to do
weed
anyway that's uh that's what happened
that was the that was mommy's night out
and um it was good it's nice to see
[ __ ]
people out there getting back to normal
and doing [ __ ] you know
i rolled into the house and i'm [ __ ]
double vaccinated and i [ __ ] walked
in and i was like didn't even think
about it people were just breathing on
me and [ __ ] and i was just like
i guess it'll be fine i guess it'll be
fine
um i woke up the next morning my throat
was dry i thought about it
i thought about a little bit too much so
uh and then i thought i was maybe
getting hype covered but it's okay even
if i do have it it's fine because i got
double vaccinated
some people never have fun you know what
i'm talking about
or actually some people just never laugh
and those people are the weirdest
[ __ ] people to me like what about
like
what about like rappers for real what
about
rappers do you ever
like i mean some rappers of course they
have a sense of humor
but you know who i'm talking about like
the rappers who are
you who are just like knobby you know
what i mean
like what about that guy what about
laughing so hard that you want to piss
yourself
nabi knobby i ain't in all that
and you're like i'm just [ __ ] making
fun of the way you eat french fries
na b not around here
you know
nah b that's that's that's for you man
that's for you dog that's for you
y'all want to do that on your own time
that's fine but nah nah not here not
here at the rocky cola cafe while i'm
eating my fries dog
and you're just like what about laughing
though dude
i know comedians that don't laugh like
[ __ ]
famous ones i've never heard them laugh
loud
ever and i'm around them all the time
because i was at the clubs and [ __ ]
and they just are just you make jokes
and everyone's laughing
from the biggest comedian to the
smallest comedian but one of them is
just like
nah b and he'll be nameless because i'm
not gonna [ __ ] call him out
because we don't tattletail on this
[ __ ] you know what i'm talking
about
uh anyway dude
here comes the comments who do you think
the comedian was the news i think it was
this guy i think was that guy it wasn't
any of the ones you're [ __ ] thinking
of
you're always wrong whenever i see those
comments you're always [ __ ] wrong
um who do you think he's talking about
when he was how he got the
how we got how he got backstabbed who do
you think it was
some guy's just like i think it was tom
papa it's just not you're never right
i tell you what dude i'll tell you what
i'm thinking of right now and what i've
been thinking of
and i want to say this with no irony
uh no funny business uh
i want to be honest about this
and i think it might
come to a it might be uh
shocking to some people but
i really mean this when i say this i am
a big
fan of the paul brothers i am a fan of
logan paul
and i am a fan of jake paul okay
period that's it no cap
okay it's lit it's so [ __ ] lit
and uh they are
what they are doing
is so [ __ ] dope
it's illegit and i will tell you
a lot of you aren't in on the joke you
don't get what they're doing
but these [ __ ] made it they did
it
by tricking you dude they're good at
what they do
they work hard as [ __ ] and you
[ __ ]
are getting mad
when you just don't get it they're
performance artists
dude i have been a logan paul fan for a
while now
i didn't know much about jake paul up
until
uh the fight he won
good for him wasn't rigged
people are like it's rigged nah i'm not
buying that [ __ ]
he [ __ ] punched him and the guy fell
down all right you win
logan works harder [ __ ] he's gonna fight
floyd mayweather dude he made it that's
the best boxer
arguably in history okay greatest of all
time
and this youtuber worked hard and did
what he did
and now he's fighting floyd mayweather
okay
he's opening up pokemon cards and [ __ ]
and being like these ones are
do you dude he found an alley
a niche he found a uh a creak in the
door and busted it why the [ __ ] open
now obviously i made the joke about the
[ __ ] twitter thing
years ago about how uh when you
die film it on youtube whatever the [ __ ]
and uh about the guy dying and i i
actually wish i didn't do that because
that was just adding to the [ __ ]
um mob the guy already felt bad himself
um had i known what i know now i
wouldn't have done that but
you know he uh is a good dude i met him
uh a few times he was at the comedy
store uh
all around good dude uh but this is
about jake paul
i didn't know much about jake paul until
the fight he won the fight i was like
okay
cool he beat a fighter uh
but the thing that
made me go all
in with jake paul happened the other day
with the floyd mayweather fight sorry
the
conference where they call it the
[ __ ] weigh-in was it the weigh-in i
don't know
whatever press conference when logan was
at the press conference with floyd
mayweather and
logan was just like a pig and [ __ ] he
was like i can't believe i'm up here
this is awesome i can't believe
by the way logan's like got this
attitude i already won and he did
who cares if he [ __ ] loses against
the greatest boxer
of all time who cares didn't i mean to
be like [ __ ] chubby checkers fought
muhammad ali who gives a [ __ ]
and uh who gives a [ __ ] if he loses he
already won
and so uh
so jake paul is there
and he's like face to face with floyd
mayweather and they're arguing
first of all if you're floyd [ __ ]
mayweather why are you
arguing any at all ever anywhere
you your life you you're the top you're
the best at what you do
you wear monochromatic outfits and you
have
14 million dollar watches do you know
what i mean and
these jake pulls in his face like [ __ ]
you this and that and floyd mayweather's
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and everyone's
around
and jake paul grabs his [ __ ] hat
send me the link of it by the way it's
on his instagram grabs
floyd mayweather's hat and says
got your hat and tucks it into his
armpit
and flipping with his bodyguards are
like drop trying to drop him
and the part that kills me about it is
he
keeps saying gotcha hat over and over
again
that is when i tell you i laughed
when i tell you i laughed i'm going to
play it for you
here yeah let's make it happen yes sir
get the pet work for this book
get out here absolutely let me call
y'all
i'm on my own one night
dude this is amazing how can you look at
that and be like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that guy he knows what
he's doing
the guy he's not a [ __ ] pigeon he's
got a brain he knows what the [ __ ] is
he knows what he's doing he's being a
[ __ ]
silly goose dude i am a [ __ ] jake
paul
fan
no irony no cap or whatever the [ __ ]
it's so freaking lit
let's make it happen yes sir get the pet
work for this boat absolutely
let me call y'all one night got your hat
oh
i'm so sweaty dude it's crazy it's good
it's good
i'm losing i'm losing weight you know
what i mean it's good i'm losing weight
and i'm getting real lean dude i'm gonna
fight one of these guys
you got a tattoo here
oh no his tattoo says gotcha hat
yeah how could you not
how could you not like this how could
you not like this
it's not
look i i think what he's doing is great
okay but if you don't
if you don't think what he's doing is
great
you are you you have to understand
that it's your fault that he's that
great
this is performance art this is
jackass but better do you understand i
know people be like [ __ ] uh jackass
was awesome
and i love stevo dude he's one of the
nicest guys and i'm not saying jackass
is bad
but they were like eating each other's
[ __ ] you know what i mean and like
throwing skateboards into their necks
he's getting a tattoo of gotcha hat
because he stole floyd mayweather's hat
he's in a posi first of all he's in that
position
to where he's arguing with the greatest
boxer
steals his hat off his head and then
gets a tattoo
of the quote he said when he did that
i think it's great but if you don't
you have to understand it's your
fault that he is that great because
you're the ones he's reacting to
people don't understand this
it's like back in the day when people
were the the joke on that [ __ ]
the howard stern movie private parts and
the guy was like
yeah well his listening has doubled and
they're like what
how's that happen he says well the
people that uh
love howard stern listen to him on
average an hour a day and they were like
what
well and they were like yeah and if the
people that hate him listen to him two
hours a day
it's like dude it's it's you you're
you're the guy
that he's talking to he wins
you [ __ ] up and i'm glad you [ __ ] up
because i want this guy in the world
i want him in the world
uh anyway
anyway i'm back let's check this hey
well let's check these let's check it
out here
dogecoin tanked cool that was cool going
to sleep and then waking up and dogecoin
tanked
yippee i'm sweatier than a [ __ ]
right now
nah b i want to read
some of these i posted a tick tock
i posted a tick tock it was some
stand-up of my [ __ ]
and it went viral my left stroke just
went
viral
the producers of that song think they
think that they think they did
they think they think the thing they did
just on a casio think they think
hand on his hip hey what's up i'm the
producer for you
for hey what's up oh nice to meet you uh
[ __ ] what's his name
the rapper left stroke just went viral
kendrick lamar nice to meet you kendrick
lamar my name is scott storm probably
anyway nice to meet you let's do it
let's do a song you like this
what do you have i got this beat hand on
his hip
think they think that they think they
they they think they think they think
that they think oh hell yeah
my left stroke just went viral
[Music]
that was just a [ __ ] scene if
anyone's home
um yeah dude
[Laughter]
i mean dude this [ __ ]
what was the [ __ ] 50 cent song the
the
wankster oh my god when that [ __ ]
when that [ __ ] song came out i was
just like did i get them
what happened what happened did i get
them
what happened
hi my name is scott storm probably
what's your name 50 cents
all right this is the producer i got
this is the song i got
hand on his hip
[Music]
and basically it just pretty much does
that for like five minutes
[Music]
dude it made [ __ ] it actually that
song i think was two minutes and 22
seconds or something like that
and i and that was song should only be
that long put your hands where my eyes
could see
buster rhymes song was two minutes 22
seconds thank you bus rhymes you did a
song that got in it got out you did your
business and i want more
so let me put it on repeat
met him once at the comedy store he said
hey i'm busta ah
oh but what do i call you that's what i
always want to say to people
who have like [ __ ] one guy said hey
what's up my name is seven
i met him at a diner he said my name is
seven what's yours and i said oh but
what do i call you
because i can't be in a position to
where i'm just calling you a number
um my left stroke just went
viral but what was i talking about why
did i bring that up
what tick tock
why did i talk about why did that even
come up dude we fly by the side of our
pants my baby that's what we do
oh viral yeah cause my [ __ ] went viral
there we go
so my thing went viral i put it on there
and i want to look at some of the
[ __ ]
it's one of my older bits well yeah it's
about four years old five years old
and uh it was about fitspo culture
which
whatever you don't need to hear it you
can go to my tick tock if you want to
but dude you got to look at these
comments
you got to look at these comments man
you got to look at these comments
when a tick tock video goes viral viral
you get the people that all of a sudden
don't understand like
if you're kind of viral you can get into
that mode where people are like oh yeah
this is cool this is funny great but if
you go really viral
you get the people that are just
absolutely brain dead
i don't know if they're [ __ ] two
years old do you know
and just learn how to work a keyboard so
i make fun of fitness influencers
and about how you know the whole joke is
dude who do you
who are you inspiring like why are you
so inspiration like who gives a [ __ ]
all you do is work out and eat extra
chicken right stupid silly joke whatever
the [ __ ]
it's not stupid it's good i think um
but look at first of all one guy
says seems beta
okay which made me laugh next guy
sounds pretty beta to me different
comment not
under his comment okay another guy says
tell me you can't bench 225 without
telling me you can't bench 225
oh oh that's sad you said that
somebody said so you're one of them huh
and it's so funny you look at these guys
dude it's so funny when you see these
guys oh the guy's got oh
dude the guy who made that comment his
profile he's wearing one of those
[ __ ] hoodies
with no sleeves on it oh dude how mixed
up in your life are you
if you're wearing a [ __ ] hoodie with
no sleeves on it you're hot or cold dude
put sleeves on get that [ __ ] hoodie
off also you're
inside the gym
get it together dude
look at this if they're proud of it let
them be proud
yeah okay that's not what i'm saying
but you know that because you're a
person somebody writes beta energy well
really throw this beta thing around
look it
look this this is great too because he's
kind of on my side this one i mean
dude's a comedian so i get it but
people do be inspiring he don't got that
fire in him i guess
[Laughter]
dude i mean dude's a comedian so i get
it
but people do be inspiring he don't got
that fire in him i guess
then a guy replies to that guy says fax
bruh
i guess lazy people don't like being
reminded that they could be doing more
and then that first guy writes to that
guy
for real for real man like
what you enjoy doing nothing all the
time
these guys are friends now they don't
they're they're
they're i don't get it friends
these two guys are two guys that are
just like
what's he talking about you don't know
either
you want to go to the movies
you got what do you know what a comedian
is why is he yelling on stage
he's with nobody i don't know
i don't know i hear people laughing but
i don't see them
you don't get it no
you want to go to cracker barrel
you want to go to red red robin
we're friends now we made friends in the
comments dude
they made friends in the comments of a
tick tock
pretty beta bud another guy
let's see what it says
oh god damn if oh this is great oh this
guy's
jacked oh he's he thinks he's more jack
knee is but the profile picture looks
jacked
he says if you're small just say that
how could you hey whoa you guys are
going to the movies
can i come
did you guys say that you were going to
red robin i did did you do you have a
table that fits
three
oh [ __ ] dude i just love it
some guy writes some do it for their
mental health
some do it because they've been bullied
their whole life some do it just because
they want to be in shape
the [ __ ] is that a paul simon song
some do it for the mental health some do
it because they've been bullied their
whole life some do it just because they
want to keep in shape
what the [ __ ] are you talking about oh
okay start a blog
you guys starting to blog in my [ __ ]
comments
you know what i mean like what's
happening
somebody said something and i can't find
it god damn it
of course i can't find it but somebody
wrote
something like that and they and they
had a
a [ __ ] profile picture of a cartoon
and uh i said
thank i said thanks a cartoon
[Laughter]
dude i i don't i don't like i just i do
it for
me you know like i [ __ ] goddamn do it
for me man
i'll do it for me like i i [ __ ]
listen bro i listen i i [ __ ] listened
to a clip of my podcast and i laughed
okay
do the [ __ ] you want to do if you're
like that's the thing it's like do the
[ __ ] that you think is good
that's the i think that this is one of
the problems with with entertainers and
performers and [ __ ] not like i'm the
best ever but like
i think people who want to be in the
entertainment industry whether it be
comedian or music
they think what do people like
i gotta do that but you gotta do what
you
you don't have to do what you like you
have to do what you think is funny or
you think is musically good
and you lose sight of that i think that
people lose sight of that but like
a painter why the [ __ ] would you paint
anything
other than a [ __ ] painting that you
like
that you would want to hang in your
[ __ ] house you know what i'm talking
about
bro i gotta be an artist so i can just
paint whatever the [ __ ] i want to
put it on my wall and be like there
that's what i wanted
god i gotta tell this [ __ ] to my son
and make sure he really breathes it in
so if you're small just say so
wow guy thought he had some real [ __ ]
there but i just
sat and laughed dude
deep belly laughs deep rolling on the
couch laughs
and i'm sweating we should have turned
the air on in the beginning and we
didn't and it's okay
now my [ __ ] body is drenched
people might think i'm a merman that
just got out of his home
but i'm a human
um but i'm jackson human
uh [ __ ] god i love it
all over
anyway i got [ __ ] my left stroke just
went viral
you guys going to red robin um i guess
that's it dude i mean i have let's see
anything else keep it moving
okay what else did i was i going to talk
about
oh i [ __ ] i gave we went to put
calvin to bed the last
it was last night and for the first time
ever you know you're not supposed to put
things in his crib
because of um because of suffocation and
[ __ ]
and uh the first night i was like
we were at my parents house for for
mother's day and uh
he he loved this moose toy that my dad
had because he directed northern
exposure and the moose was the mascot
thing for the
northern exposure thing and um
he loved it he was just like taking the
moose and looking at it he was dancing
with it and
ripping it back and forth and [ __ ] and
having a good time with it for never
likes a
stuffed animal this much and [ __ ]
loved the moose
and um so we were like can we bring it
and my dad was like of course
and then so we brought it home and i was
like this is a good first toy
that he could sleep in the crib with and
i was like so cute so i put in the moose
in the crib with him and he just went
out immediately
and uh the moose was just chilling in
the in the
in the crib all night you know and it
was so cute every now and then i would
check it and i would see him sleeping
and he would be in a different position
sometimes on his face sometimes on his
back sometimes doing a [ __ ]
michael jordan pose like he's about to
dunk and the moose was always in the
same place
i woke up in the morning and i looked in
the nanite and the moose was [ __ ]
nowhere to be found and i was like what
the [ __ ] and we walked in and then moose
was on the floor
and i was like isn't that just a [ __ ]
isn't that just how life is you know
you think it's going to go one way and
it just goes another
i thought he liked the [ __ ] moose not
in the morning apparently that's a
[ __ ] nighttime toy
he woke up in the middle of the night
and just goes like this the [ __ ] does my
dad think
that just be what the [ __ ] does my dad
think
that he can put this toy in the crab
first of all
i'm just trying to like rag my brain at
this point have ever had a toy in the
crib now so i sleep fine
i've heard him talk about on the power
caps before that i sleep fine
i'm my [ __ ] good sleeper i thought
i don't know why he would change that
thing i hope that this is what he's
thinking because this means that
so it's been good this means he's a
dalia it's been good
you know sleeping's been good been
sleeping 13 hours straight through
tonight have i woke up crying once no i
never have even when i have tummy eggs
everyone have pains from shots that they
give me i got tommy eggs don't wake them
up i know that they need their sleep and
i wanted to be a good kid
and all of a sudden he's going to just
put moose in there
that's hard
just toss it out i hope when they wake
up and they come in there now
they see that that now
they know that this student is going to
surpass
that teacher i am going to be
the craziest delay of all time
there will be no mooses or any stuffed
animal of any nature
in my crab
from now till eternity and i will sleep
in a crib
for the rest of my life because i will
be
the craziest delay of all time
[Music]
um [ __ ] all right guys uh i'm done and
i'm done because i'm hot
temperature and looks um
have a good time have a good night i
hope you really enjoyed it dude sign up
for the patreon
really it [ __ ] and go to crystal.com
we got merch
but sign up for the patreon dude go look
at the tears you know just [ __ ] surf
around and be like
all right send it to a friend
if you like the pockets tell another
friend about it send them a [ __ ]
youtube clip you know what i mean
do you the diligence wow [ __ ] that word
up hey guys that's it for the episode on
youtube
if you sign up for the patreon you can
get the longer extended
uncut episode of this episode
uh and you can also get a bunch of free
bonus content if you sign up for the
patreon and you can also get uh
one extra episode a month uh you know
it's like it's a good it's good so go
check out
uh patreon.com crystalia
go check it out and sign up if you'd
like
[Music]
congratulations
thank you
hold on hold on um and then chili
cheese fries
uh vegetarian ranch
on side